في كل موسم الانتخابيه تبرز قضايا وهواجس
تشكل اهتماما الناخبين الامريكيين
وبوصلتهم في اختيار مرشحهم في الغالب هي
قضايا تتكرر كل موسم الانتخابي مثل
الرعايه الصحيه وفرص العمل والهجره غير
الشرعيه ومستوى الجريمه وعنف السلاح لكن
في انتخابات التشجير النصفيه هذا العام
ابرزت الظروف قضيتين غير مالفتين هيمنتا
على الساحه الانتخابيه
في وفقا لاحد استطلاعات الراي يرى ثلاثون
في المئه من الامريكيين ان التضخم هاجسهم
الاكبر فعلى الرغم من اللجوء الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي الى رفع نسب الفائده بغيه كبح
جموح الانفاق عاد معدل التضخم لتسجيل اعلى
نسبه الله منذ 40 عاما وقد وصلت تضخم
العام في شهر سبتمبر الماضي الى ثمانيه
فاصله اثنين في المئه مقارنه بالعام
السابق الج ولجعلوا من التضخم والاقتصاد
اساسا لحملاتهم الانتخابيه متسلحين
بافضليه يتمتعون بها لدى الناخب الامريكي
ارى 39% من الامريكيين ان الحسبه الجمهوري
سيقوم بعمل افضل في التعامل مع الاقتصاد
مقابل
26% يفضلون الديمقراطيين القضيه الثانيه
على سلم اولويات الناخب الامريكي هي
الاجهاض
22% اعتبروه قضيتهم الانتخابيه الاولى بعد
قرار المحكمه العليا نزع الاحقيه
الدستوريه عنها وبعد قيام عدد من مجالس
الولايات الجمهوريه بتجرمها بل توجهات لدى
الجمهوريين في الكونغرس لحظره على المستوى
الوطني وتزداد اولويه القضيه الديمقراطيين
حيث يرى 35% منهم انه قضيتهم الاولى
وقد جعل الحزب منها ركنا من اركان حملاته
الانتخابيه بغيت استماله صوت المراه
الامريكيه القلقه من مسعى الجمهوريين لحظر
امر كان حقا دستوريا تمتعت به لنحو خمسه
عقود